well everybody in the audience please run
the tip of his tongue ovaries teeth just
to get into the spirit of the story please
that's right thank you just like that oh
that's the idea thank you and what do you
find anything wrong bridge works missing
T that's what I thought well that's what
the story is about about teeth about Danny
Smith teeth in particular and here's Danny
applying for an important job what do his
teeth have to do with it well are they helping
him or spoiling his appearance and his chances
and if they are helping him how did they
get the way they are just luck or walk or
the answer to that will have to go back to the
years to the time when Danny was 2 months old
not thinking about teeth no teeth to think
about and there still is much doing on the
dental pot six months later when Danny ruled
over in the order of their appearance mother
father and his grandmother completing the
family growth what's going on here young
Danny seems to have discovered something
can it be that this is Danny's first
yes that's what it is Danny's first - there it
is all alone in a strange place but then comes
company well Danny getting along here here he
is way past - his mother has plans for him an
informant mr. Smith of her decisions listen
I want to take Danny to the dentist what's
the matter you got a toothache he said that
all children should be taken to the dentist
as soon as their baby teeth cut through the gum
now what could be wrong with Danny's piece of
his age nothing well I still think y'all
see you didn't you had some time tomorrow
why don't you come along and see what dr. Jones
has to say I think it's a silly idea Danny has
better teeth and I have more of them too they
forget the whole thing so they went to the net
how do you do mrs. Mary Sam and Danny chief how
do you do dr. Jones how do you do mr. Smith my
wife doesn't cyst on having Danny's teeth examined
although I don't see why that's necessary I'm sure
there's nothing wrong with them maybe not but
this we can't be absolutely sure of that until
we've given his teeth a careful examination
it may even be necessary to x-ray them x-ray
that's right they're doing a great deal with x-ray
these days in fact I just received a bulletin from
the American Dental Association showing some of
their recent findings perhaps you'd be interested
in seeing some of them I'm sure we would yes yes
of course it's really amazing the things they're
accomplishing these days these cavities were
so small that the I might have missed him but
they didn't escape the x-ray yes but if they're
so small they can't be harmful why bother with
them where elephants small cavity is neglected
it always develops into a large one treatment
becomes more unpleasant takes more time and costs
more money I hear this tooth was filled as soon
as decay appears and this tooth was neglected
and the decay spread if such a condition is
not corrected it will result in the loss of the
tooth yes they're baby teeth but they're very
important nevertheless if they're decayed they
will interfere with the child's ability to chew
his food and may have a bad effect on a general
health but that's only part of the story early
loss of the baby tooth may cause the adult case
to come in crooked well the things of this baby
teeth are important after all as usual my wife
was right there is still another important reason
for coming here at this time the child's first
experience with the dentist will be a pleasant
one it means an examination possibly an x-ray
and Dakini consequently he won't mind coming for
periodic checkups I'd like to know what Danny he's
our own right and let's get started and dr. Jones
makes friends with Danny makes him feel right
at home child psychology they call it nowadays
Danny is a tease he has complete confidence in
the doctor the examination is all part of the
fun Danny in toys and his parents are relieved
for a dr. Jones predicted Danny's first visit
to the dentist to the pleasant one it will
be remembered as good fun when the time the
next visit rolls around four months from now
Danny won't have to be coaxed and the visit
was an informative one for Danny's parents they
learned a great many surprising things about
teeth that day for instance dr. Jones told the
Smiths they could walk along anywhere and stop
almost anybody and find that they have decayed
teeth yes anybody at all this young woman for
instance she is unaware of her neglect but look
the x-ray reveals her filling which represents
previous decay taken care of but here is a new
cavity that needs immediate attention what of
this enterprising young merchant selling service
with a smile a happy lad with laughing merry eyes
assuredly he has rhythm and maybe a song in his
heart what was the day his teeth have decayed
observed the x-ray shows he has a large cavity
in the baby tooth that he will soon lose and a
new cavity on the biting surface of a second to
baby teeth going out second teeth coming in and
decay in both yes sir coming out and going the
doctor told the Smiths of such as this retired
lawmaker why it's enough to make a nation's laws
but not wise enough to take care of his teeth
just roll your eyes over this x-ray absent the gay
anything wrong is there anything that isn't wrong
let's examine the case of this in a hurry
gentlemen at one time or another almost
everybody has decayed teeth and what do most of
them do well let's see what he does he thinks it
over very carefully besides he's too busy to take
care of a little cavity it doesn't hurt and after
all what's a little cavity once go by and the
ear goes by and then what happened the little
cavity has become a big cavity and the little
pain is a big pain so suddenly he's not too busy
he wouldn't bother with a cavity so he'll have
to bother with bridge work and he didn't want
to run up a little bill so now it's a big film
after all what's a little cavity getting back
to the Smiths dr. Jones told them there are
three ways of brushing teeth this way inside
the size or the floor washing method very
effective for washing floors this is known
as the circular or window washing treatment
also very effective for washing windows and
here is the right way the upper teeth are
brushed with the downward motion the lower
teeth with an upward motion and the chewing
surfaces are brushed by putting the brush
into the grooves and vibrating it backward and
false sounds complicated but anybody can learn
well here's Danny again 8 years old today and
having himself a time celebrating the occasion
Danny's building himself up to a terrific case
of ontology - thanks to you and a toothache by
any name hurts just as much as Danny is
beginning to find out teeth can take so
much punishment from sweets as we can see in
this picture of decay getting started on the
surface of a first tooth then slowly cutting
through until the tooth has become infected at
the end of one of the rooms yes Danny doesn't
feel so good he has a very low opinion of candy
at the moment but it wasn't all the Candy's fault
as mrs. Smith realized he hadn't followed through
on Danny's teeth she kept the appointments
for several years and then well like a lot
of mothers she forgot results trouble well better
late than never but unfortunately it is too late
too late to save the infected moment for dr.
Jones had to extract it to prevent further
complications he told mrs. Smith how serious an
infected tooth can be he showed her how decay
begins and when neglected penetrates the enamel
and attacks the inner part of the teeth how it
permitted the decay spreads and spreads sometimes
causing an abscess and an abscess like this means
going going and mrs. Smith properly sorry resolved
that no such neglect would occur again all that
was 16 years ago what happened to Danny well our
frantic cameraman brings us up to today and here
is Danny a healthy confident looking young man
24 here is his mother a bit older a bit grayer
and if possible a bit prouder of death this is
an eventful day in the Smith household and the
gaze smiles and cheery banter of mother and son
are just make-believe to conceal the anxiety each
field where Danny has an appointment downtown
for a new job that's going to mean a lot to him
it's the job he was applying for when we first
met him back at the start of the tour we asked
you if his personal appearance would aid in his
landing the job and what part his teeth played and
how necessary wasn't to take good care of that the
answers seemed pretty obvious in the light of what
we've seen good looking teeth and good looking
appearance go hand in hand if you have any doubt
about how strong healthy teeth compliment a lovely
face this picture is of our faces there's this
young lady's lovely teeth helped make the lady
love ice she's always helped we don't appreciate
how essential they are until we make comparisons
and speaking of comparisons let's make some D
gentlemen answer the purpose very well would you
say there was competition from Robert Taylor here
or here or here after all what's a little cavity
and here's the business appointment that started
us on this line of things we sought to prove that
good sound teeth are a must if we would be healthy
but they are a must if we value our personal
appearance we feel danny has proved the point
of our argument but what about keeping our teeth
that way how does Danny handle that mud let's see
one slipped by on the new job long hours hard
work and lost in the immediate problems before
him danny is forgetting forgetting that important
date he has with the dentist on June 18th June
18th Danny that's today and you're supposed to
go to the dentist remember no he doesn't remember
well we've got some bad history he doesn't know
it yet but one of his teeth is beginning to decay
the strange part of it is Danny takes good care of
his teeth for example heats good solid food very
little sweets but his teeth are decaying anyway
that's how teeth are there's no way of stopping
the decay cept by going to a dentist having it
removed and the tooth filled Danny brushes his
teeth every day and properly - that doesn't
stop decayed his teeth and your teeth need
more than a bath they need a dentist well as you
guessed danny has entirely forgotten his dental
appointment in his enthusiasm for the new job he
has fallen into the neglect comment - so many of
us he just doesn't realize how he'll look if he
loses that - it does make a difference doesn't it
Danny is going to be just another man who wouldn't
bother with a little cavity that is unless
something happens unless something warns him of
the dangers Wow well that's not a warning the cold
water did the treasure and he's lucky it happened
before the decay had gone too far yes the cold
water was the pause that remembers the pause that
made him remember he forgot and before you and I
can say see your dentist regularly Danny will be
sitting in the dentist chair and the tooth has
been saved it has a filling but it has been saved
and Danny's had a lesson he's going to remember
to visit the dentist three times a year he's going
to remember that only regular treatment can check
decay and help guard against the loss of teeth
that's pretty much the story ladies and gentlemen
the story of Danny Smith it might have
been the story of you or you or you of
the fellow next door the girl down the block
it might well be the story of this young man
paying the first visit to the death and
happily bringing our story at the end